сьогодні миша candida пальцевого вище
кови та cv черв'яки
чорну березня з голоду вседержитель
комісій активно завозити ви продуктів тієї
на вулицю людино жилося вийти лише цю
день ікло вклонилася артилерійські
обстріли можливості проплати харчів
дебальцеве mu-mimo я теж доводиться їх
просто
просто у нас місто зруйноване просто
місцям на поганого на я інфраструктура
вся подвійного на магазини пляшки ми ви
чоловік і не стоять і в чарлі за хлібом там
вже чуєва не доб'єш і взятої сепаратисти
організовувати пан продуктивно
гуманітарна допомога та вид
міжнародних організацій здається ще
допомогу надають усім назвеш на вигляд
політичних поглядів на був у справі
камус видай йому допомогти нам і дай йому там
ще була гуманітарна катастрофа
було голодні калових віддалася підвалі
ходили з підвалів відсіку вати швидкого
приборкання унітарної ситуації на сході
україни навряд чи варто пропускати
німецький політолог
ганзен шредер офіційно ви знання на
підконтрольних києву районів донеччини
то луганщини тим годинного купава на ви
поважаючи раніше символічним актом фейкових
тильта шпилем безриб'я він з точки зоря
міжнародного права ті райони та піт
порядковій у тебе українському уряду
києві теж вин і адже за виглядом я за
запуск дуже вузькі киш сепаратисти
поважають законі влади дієта are on
the wait is забезпечення людей та поїдання
за цілий жити на самих сепаратистах
дозволю на руси infant форум за рецептом
відвиснути з легкої russland
незалежна форма офіційного статусу вже
чи то окупованих територій на
завищувати об і спить рамка з Європи з
крима знімати чини
люди всіх регіонах чоловік поза сум не
вам розруху і ти на подалі допомогу
громадам здавати і митися і чи треба мати
доступ даних поки я знову дсп брати я
коли звуть нам доставити людям що їм
потрібно ти їх ще правда гуманітарно
допомога не ви вирішити масштабних
інфраструктурних проблем так світлана
збентежена до сюжету підвалі
до вибору валібурі за місцем та квартиру в
найкращих снаряд і шо видихнув
будь-яку в ній повз і нічого доброго
підвалах життя нічого хорошого в підвал
може тина мається інакше навіщо це люди
але в коробці вигляд сірниці kill
вони води вони світла нічого ну підвал
холодно сиру
смердіти ви його не снаряд ланкою вами
буду ніг людмили доведе місяць вигляд буду
мати на увазі видається за наве ряд сбн до
вдома розуму наймаючи
жетони модель я живу за раз у людей
дякую добрим людям допам кути а далі
я не знаю навіть цього
води та п'яний вигляд буду у дружини моане сил
вони кішки на і бірж темний об'єкт і
пальцевого за різні вузи тежу руїнах
світлана 20 руки проти алана залазите
у нас році я українська армія то
сепаратисти так запікало було зв'язатися та
об'єкт рахунок руїни валу його в сент на
адже рази пудову ти пальці вагони
розуміється жадібно assist орен конфлікту